But the people you can really learn from
are the people who are somewhat disappointed
if they can't,
if they couldn't use your product every day.
Nadia Tatlow, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
Good.
Nice to meet you finally.
Definitely.
Thank you for being here.
Vast experience in PR and marketing,
the CEO of Shift.
I want to go back before we get
into your professional journey.
Where do you come from
and how do you go on your journey
wanting to become at the end
the CEO of a startup?
Yeah, I guess so.
So, I am Canadian,
based in Victoria, BC.
And that's where Shift is,
has been founded and grown from day one.
So, the whole team is based here
on the West Coast.
My background, I actually moved to Victoria
about seven years ago from Toronto.
So, I did my undergrad and schooling
at Queen's University in Kingston.
And years before that
I had moved around a lot
growing up with my family.
So, I think I've always been
very entrepreneurial
about the way I approach work.
And that's kind of been
a theme from day one for me.
I've also, I think,
lived in a lot of different places,
and that has influenced a lot about,
I think, the way I work
and the way I want to work,
and just how I think about work in general.
So, I think, yeah, when I found Victoria,
to be honest, I moved here because I thought
it was such a beautiful city.
I have some family here.
So, there is that was kind of calling me
from moving across the country in my 20s.
So, yeah, I think
wanting to be able to live in Victoria
and build a company and sort of
achieve all the things in my career
that I want to do.
It seemed like a
kind of an awesome opportunity
when I originally took a job out on Victoria
to start building that out.
And yeah,
I couldn't be happier to be here, I'd said.
It's not a bad place to be even.
Even through this covid and pandemic stuff
we're all going through.
So, how do you find yourself?
You're starting with PR and marketing.
You've held several positions
in that world before initiating Shifts.
So, what was it about that industry
that interested you?
And why made the transition later on
to becoming the CEO of Shift?
Yeah.
So I guess the reason I got into PR,
I remember the first time I heard
what public relations was,
I was actually doing a,
in university,
I took a summer job at a daycare
like a Montessori daycare.
And I got chatting with one of the parents
that I just seemed kind of like a cool guy.
And I remember he had founded
his own PR consulting business.
And so, that was really my first time
getting any introduction to what PR was.
I did my undergrad in political science.
So, and I love talking about politics.
I love that world of.
So I, but I often realized
I was graduating post 2008
and realizing political science
wasn't the direct path
into the kind of job that I wanted to get.
So, after talking to him,
I remember thinking,
you know what, this is such an amazing
kind of introduction into business.
And I think a lot about business
comes down to PR.
And whether it's kind of business PR
and brand PR or personal PR,
it's all very important.
And also telling the story
and the narrative about your work
or your company or yourself
is so critical to success.
So, I decided to do a postgrad program
in public relations.
Met a bunch of amazing people through that.
And it was a great network
to jumpstart my career.
So, that launched me into working
at a marketing agency in Toronto,
which I really enjoyed.
But ultimately, I think I saw myself
moving more into the product side.
I think I saw the highs and lows
of what it is to work in an agency
and you learn a lot and you move fast
and you really learn of the service role
and you get to exposure
to so many cool brands and products.
But I think I realized pretty quickly
that I wanted to build something of my own
and really kind of be the person
behind the brand rather than
kind of serving someone else's.
So, there comes Shift.
So, what is Shift?
What are you trying to do there?
So Shift,
I think in the shortest amount of words
is a browser for work.
So, we started shift about three years ago.
Really as a really solving for the pain point
of multiple email accounts.
So, and there's a little bit of back story
in that. Shift actually spun out
of a company I was working at.
So, I was managing marketing
across a bunch of different brands
at a company here in Victoria.
And there are a few of us that sort of
would jump on a project every time we had
a new idea to, or a product idea,
we would sort of fire up nadia@,
whatever this new product idea was.
So, domain and email,
and that meant calendar,
and drive associated with each of those.
So, we were very much in this world
of multiple email accounts.
Like I think I had seven or eight
at the time we launched Shift.
So, that's one side
of the workflow pain point
that we were solving for.
But we approached Shift from day one as
we have this pain point ourselves.
Let's build something to solve for this
and then see the reaction and the response
and sort of build iteratively
on the product from there.
So, almost as soon as we launched Shift,
we started getting feedback that people,
like this is amazing,
I also have this pain point.
A lot of people working in design
or marketing or consulting businesses
where they also kind of lived
the same experience as us.
And then they, but they also
often had extensions and apps.
And basically all these other things
they were doing at work in the browser
that they wanted to move out.
So, that really fired up our engine
and told us that we had early signal
of product market fit.
And that really kind of
the vision for Shift was much, much bigger
than an email service
that was really a browser for work.
So, when you say browser for work,
what does it actually mean tangibly?
If I go to Shift right now,
what would I see?
Yeah, so,
you can download Shift at tryshift.com
It's a downloadable desktop app.
So, it sits on your computer,
just like if you use the Slack's desktop app
It's a similar download experience.
So, basically,
it's built on the electron framework,
which is actually the same framework
that Slack is built on.
And you download it for free,
you set it up,
and then we have a premium experience
that you can upgrade to
if you decide you need all the apps
and all the extensions,
unified search, workspaces, all that.
So really, the way I look at it is
most of us now will operate
throughout our workday with
a browser open at all times.
And everyone has a very different workflow.
Some people open multiple browser windows
to organize their workflow.
Some people actually have the,
are consistent about Gmail profiles,
and that's amazing if you are.
And so, they'll organize work and personal
and whatever else they do by Gmail profiles.
Other people will use multiple browsers.
So Safari, Chrome, Edge,
whatever it is that you like.
But what we found is that
this workflow experience
is very different for everyone.
And there's no one way
that everyone likes to work
and is consistent about working.
So, we want to kind of give you
this flexibility with Shift,
but also spoon feed you
a much more organized,
sort of streamlined experience
so you can actually get work done
and stop having to do the administrative,
like there's a lot of buzz about there,
out there, about work about work.
So, trying to remove
that work about work for you,
so that you can actually do focused work
and kind of eliminate distractions.
So, if you're looking at your insights
into the product
and it's interesting because you say
you transition from PR and marketing
[--]
and more towards the product, and then,
really going through that
entrepreneur process of finding
product market fit,
doing the spinning off of different products,
pivoting and then finding your sweet spot.
What were some of your aha moments
along the way with Shift that you set up?
I now understand, I have an insight
that a lot of others may not have right now.
Yeah, I think that's an interesting one.
I think it's been very,
like sometimes I think about the way
we approach the business very much
as horse before the cart.
So, I think my background in marketing
and the company that we spun out of,
it was very much along
the performance minded
when it came to marketing.
So, prove that there's product market fit
before you overinvest in building a cart
that might not solve the right problem.
So, it was an aha moment when,
and probably the biggest aha moment
in the early days when
our customers started asking for,
and very early customers
started asking for extensions and apps.
And basically, okay, this is
we want more than just email.
Email's kind of a focus point,
but it's not, it's not our entire workday.
So, they were asking for that.
And you always have to balance out,
I think, running a company,
how much you listen to customers,
and how long you wait,
and how many requests for something.
Especially in the early days,
you need to pile up
before you really take action.
But it was so clear.
So, that was aha moment very early on,
I think,
I think now what we're working on
is really more focused on
how to help people
work better together in Shift.
So this has been another really,
I think aha moment.
We all have our workflows
and sort of our,
I think our individual work styles.
And with Shift, it's interesting because
we talk a lot about tab hoarding
and sort of that mess
that can pile up on your computer
that you actually
don't want anyone else to see.
I'm looking at that mess right now.
Yeah.
I mean, by the end of a workday,
with you're at, I guess,
you could have dozens of tabs,
open windows,
and you don't even know
where your day started or ended.
Yeah, and then that's a pretty common.
[--] you just close all of them
because you would just want to start scratch.
You don't even want to understand
what you had over there.
It's awful. Every day the same thing.
Totally.
Yeah.
And I think that's so common.
But there's also sign of
sort of some shame around that.
So, we wanted to help people
streamline that and also sort of
better prepare themselves for when you're,
especially with all this
work from home stuff.
When you're jumping on a video call
with someone and then all of a sudden
they want you to share your screen,
and you want to look and feel prepared.
So, we built a layer on Shift
called, workspaces.
And essentially you can think of that as
like a focused collection of
tabs, apps, bookmarks,
that you would actually
want to work with someone else on.
So, you can easily just share it
with your collaborators,
and then there you go.
You've got this clean place
to get stuff done.
So, that was a big aha moment, too.
Is that as individual
as your personal workflow every day is,
we don't work in silos.
Most of us don't work by ourselves.
And I think the more we work from home,
and the more we're forced
to do Zoom for everything,
the more we kind of have to
put purpose back in
in the way we work together.
Right.
I think it's really interesting.
One of the things that I
was fascinated by this past year,
in one of my classes at Stanford,
we read a case study
about Superhuman, by Rahul,
in a first round magazine.
And it was talking about
how he found his sort of NPS score,
and how he figured out
who are his target customers
and how to accelerate their growth
in certain areas of his company
to target those customers.
Do you have any process
that you're thinking through:
how do I understand,
how do I cluster my customers,
and how do I really make sure
I maximize on those
that really love our product?
Yeah. That's interesting.
I think Superhuman
has done an amazing job of that
and of understanding their core audience
and in speaking to them.
Even the onboarding flow that they did
and the fact that it's really all,
they force the word of mouth.
Like, I think, I think you still have to have
an introduction to their team
in order to get Superhuman.
So, you can't even just download it, right?
Which is really interesting.
And it really allows for that word of mouth,
but across the Internet
to feel a lot more authentic.
So, what we do is we really, I mean,
we definitely see demographic consistencies
and groupings of people
that we know Shift will really speak to.
But I think our audiences
is very, very broad.
And the more diverse and broadly
we can speak to people, the better.
So, we do things like,
there are surveys within Shift
where we we ask things about job title
and an industry,
so that we can better understand
and better cater to each of those people.
We end up seeing a lot of,
I think millennials are a huge part
of our core audience
because so many of us have a work life,
maybe a side hustle and a personal life
that all a lot of those
part of those lives happen on the Internet.
So, you have email accounts
and calendars and apps
that go with each one.
So, helping people organize
and make sense of that work life balance
that I think we're all trying to achieve.
So, we see consistency with that.
But with the onboarding process
and even NPS scores, actually Superhuman
did a really interesting
survey of their users
that we also, we saw in and ended up using
for our customer base as well,
where they asked the customer base:
how disappointed would you be
if you no longer had whatever products
of Superhuman or Shift?
And that was awesome.
Because it's kind of, the results,
we actually got the exact same results
with our audiences as he had laid out
in his article about it,
where I think it was 25% of people
were very disappointed if no Shift,
50% were somewhat disappointed
and 25% were not disappointed.
And those results have been for a lot of
what we do and who we do it for.
The key point that really stuck with me
with that is that
you're always going to have this 25%,
well, you're not always,
but you really are amazed
by this 25% kind of super fans.
And we get those ambassadors
that Shift is their daily driver
and they can't live without it.
And we love those people.
And we love talking to those people
and getting their feedback.
But the people you can really learn from
are the people who are somewhat disappointed
if they can't, if they couldn't use
your product every day.
So, really kind of digging into
where that somewhat came from,
has been a great or very informative
exercise for us.
I think one of the things that I took away
from during that exploration
and understanding,
and as a Superhuman fan myself,
it was about understanding
that it's okay to sort of give up
on certain groups and focus on others.
And I think it's almost intuitive for us
to see that there is a group
that really doesn't care.
And you're almost insulted
that they don't care.
So, you want to work to win their validity
and get them to join you.
And you sort of and you don't realize that
they might not be the right group
to maximize your efforts.
And especially if you're a fast growing
early stage startup,
you can only focus so much of your energy
on certain areas.
And it's definitely important to know
where to focus them.
What has been the most challenging
and most rewarding
part of this journey for you?
And one of the things
that I wanted to bring up
that we didn't get to discuss was,
you didn't actually start out
as the CEO of Shift, right?
You started out as a general manager there.
You've proven yourself,
and then, you became the CEO.
But what were some of the biggest
challenges and rewards along the way?
Yeah.
I think the challenges are kind of tied
into exactly what you just said, which is,
especially with Shift,
like our audience is basically anyone
who uses a browser at work all day,
which is all of us.
And we can prioritize
the way we approach customer acquisition,
which is really a big part
of our competitive edge and how
we've really grown as fast as we had.
So, I think,
I think it's segmenting your audience
when you have them.
It's very exciting to have
a massive audience.
It's also a huge technological
or technical challenge.
But it's really, you know,
finding ways to spice and dice that audience
so you can tackle
the most important pieces first
and speak to the most important
audiences first.
So now I think three years in,
it's fun to be able to have a core engine
of people that we know we can reach
and reach very efficiently.
But then consistently sort of layer on
and broaden who we speak to
and how we speak to them.
So, that's a big focus right now,
is is really broadening that.
Second part of your question,
what was the other part?
Sorry?
The rewards.
Some of the most rewarding moments.
Yeah. The rewarding part about it is,
I think, building a team.
Like building a team is so critical to,
I mean, ultimately,
you go from kind of doing everything yourself
with a couple other people.
And then really sort of hiring the people
who are ultimately going to build the product
in the later stages.
So, I think,
it's rewarding and challenging,
but I think a lot about
the creator, the builder and the optimizer
and where we're at now.
Where we have
a significant customer base of people
that are using Shift every day
to drive their workday.
We have a lot of responsibility
to those people.
So, there's a ton of optimizations
and bug fixes and requests
and customer success,
targets that we're dealing with all day.
So, that is a huge part of the business now
that we have this responsibility
to these customers year over year.
But you have to just keep creating
and you have to keep building.
So, balancing that out.
And then I think ultimately
identifying people on your team
as one of those
or some combination of those.
It's definitely not black and white.
And people evolve over time.
But at the stage we're at,
we do need all three of those.
And I think there is, it's exciting because
there's so much opportunity
for everyone on the team
to sort of evolve into the positions
that are best for them
and sort of grow with the company.
So, yeah, I think, that's rewarding
and that's rewarding for me.
I think a lot about it as almost manifesting
our own growth trajectory
and manifesting what we want
out of our own career,
which has always been
sort of my driving force.
100%. I think that's just wonderful.
I want to thank you for being so generous
with your time.
20 minutes go by very, very fast.
And I really appreciate
you taking time to do this.
Before we leave,
I have to put you on the spot one time,
and I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Or if I ask anybody
that is working with you or for you,
what are three words
that they would use to describe Nadia?
I think,
probably excitable,
open minded and hardworking.
I love it.
Nadia, thank you so, so much.
This is really great.
And I can't wait to share this
with the world.
Thank you so much, Michael.